Shall we?
Sorry.
Yeah.
Okay. Hello everyone. I'm Noa Mosslander.
I'm co-chairing,
and I'm from the Wistar Institute in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania.
Thank you for coming for this mini symposium. We have very exciting talks today.
Hello, everyone. I'm Alexander Anderson.
I'm the chair of the Integrated Mathematical Oncology Department at
Moffitt Cancer Center, and we use a lot of machine
learning approaches in our work. But this little collection of
talks that we're going to have today really spans quite a
width of the submissions that we received
this year. So I'm really looking forward to this session.
We've got everything from LLMs to more,
let's call it, standard machine learning approaches.
So for the speakers, you're going to have 15 minutes total,
so you can choose to have some questions at the end of your talk, but
that means you'll need to use less than 15 minutes, so maybe something like a
12 plus three. We're going to try and keep very strict to the
schedule. We don't want people running over, so we'll give you that three-minute
warning when you're getting close to it, okay?
So I think we should just get straight into it, dive straight in and start
with our first speaker,
and that's Kai Wang, who's going to tell us about CUPIA
2, a collaborative multi-agent large language
model framework for diagnosis of cancer of unknown
primary.
So Kai.
Thank you. Thanks to ACR and session chair.
I'm going to introduce you to CUPIA 2.
It's a collaborative multi-agent large language model designed to predict a
tissue's origin in cancers of unknown
primary.
Actually, its impact beyond CUP diagnosis
or any cancer patient with NGS report, it functions as
we call it, molecular second opinion, delivered automatically in few
second at no extra cost.
My disclosure.
Okay, let me start with a case. This is a 58 years old
patient with an isolated liver mass.
So biopsy seeing poorly differentiated adenocarcinoma,
but IHC is inconclusive. So from this patient, we
can see probably it's a lung adenocarcinoma, could be the ovarian,
so there's no conclusion, but this is the CUP, the issue.
So it's account to almost 5% of the all
malignancy. It's one of the leading reasons of cancer death.
But luckily, this patient, like most of the patients today, has NGS report
available. So we put all the mutation results like the KRAS,
TP53, two gene losses, all to CUPIA
2 return as a prediction. The top one, pancreatic,
followed by colorectal, gastric adenocarcinoma.
But beyond that, there's a reasoning rationale, as you see, for
example, KRAS G12D together, TP53
R175H co-mutation happened in
2.2% of the pancreatic, versus almost
1% of CRC, and the SMARCA4 loss was
observed in 2.2% PDAC and so on.
So this is not generated by AI. This is not from the website, from our own
database. It's called Smart Data.
It's a Retrospectively de-identified e-hospital database of 100,000 cancer
patients, match the genomics and pathology clinical
input together. So there are two rules for
CUPIA 2. One is training CUPS, and the
second is a reasoning substrate in inference.
So back to the clinical question. So we know CUP issue, but actually I
would argue more than CUP. So for example, let me ask, if you're
seeing a lung squamous cell carcinoma,
but from the NGS result, you found an ALK
fusion. So what would you do? I think certainly we have to go
back to pathology to ask, "Okay, can you double-check this is a lung
adenocarcinoma, or you are sure this is just a squamous cell?" But in most of
case, you know this is adenocarcinoma.
So this is not rare, especially if you see, like us, 100,000
cancer patients already. Nothing is really rare.
So from the literature, also combined HCC cholangiocarcinoma
study, almost half of them misclassed as HCC on
image alone.
Similarly to the things has been observed in soft tissue sarcoma,
in the lung adenocarcinoma.
So unlike morphology and IHC, genomic signature
seeing biology different. So they encode tissues of origin
independent of appearance under microscope.
So our objective is not only about CUP issue.
So we hope to turn existing NGS data into a molecular
second opinion.
Okay, come to the methodology. Why choose the multiple agent large
language model? So traditional machine learning require
hand-engineered feature and lose variant context.
Single fine-tune LLM has the information bottleneck, sometimes
has a poor probability correction.
Even the most experienced oncologist cannot really interpret all the NGS
report results simply because there are too many gene, too much
information update almost every day.
So our conclusion is just like molecular tumor board.
So there is a multiple specialist and the chairman
adjudicate.
So we just used a whole precise
imageSo here is the architecture
of CUB AI 2.
It was changed on over 20,000 cancer patients across
19 cancer types. So as you list here, also, we
use all class of genomic alteration, including point mutation, short
variance, indel, copy number change, and a structural variation
like fusion and translocation. So there are three tiers
totally.
Tier one is a genomic specialist. So there are three
heterogeneous compact, large language model, each one
fine-tuned independently, output a probability
class.
So tier two is a statistical coordinator.
So this is not a simple average, it's really learn when to trust
each specialist and which option matters through the combination.
So it's a non-linear stacked generalization.
So tier three, as we talked, like a chairman in the board,
usually we use a larger model. Could use a DeepSeek or
Gemini. If you want to do completely local, you could use a Qwen
72B. So what chairman does, it
validate, arbitrate, justify, and it can
overwrite the ensemble result. In our case,
chairman overwrite 24% of the case total from
training.
Okay, come to the performance. Across all the 19 cancer type,
CUB AI 2 achieved almost 77% at top
one accuracy,
93% at top three. So from some
certain cancer type with a clear genomic signature, for
example, lung adenocarcinoma.
So, it achieved F1 score over 85%.
But also we know the weakness. For example, small cell lung cancer
and endometrial, the F1 score is lower.
We are trying to solve this issue for the retraining.
Okay, compared to the baseline, sometimes pattern matter than headline.
So traditional machine learning, sometimes they suffer from the lower
micro recall because sometimes average accuracy could be
misleading. As you've seen from the bar plot, like the traditional
machine learning, random forest or logistic regression, they have
a reasonable top one accuracy, but they drop to only
35% as a micro recall, means they can do pretty good some
major class but lose the balance for minor.
So CUB AI 2 achieve leading almost 67% micro
recall, almost 2% improve over machine learning.
That means a good balance for both major and the minor cancer
types.
So this is not internal artifacts anymore.
So we have deployed the things on website so everyone can use
it. It's free. It's cubai2.origmed.ai.
So upload the genomic data or just a single copy-paste.
They will show you a ranked prediction of a premise ID,
not only showing the prediction, but also there is a
rationale showing the reason from our in-house
database, over 100,000 cancer patients.
So we did a validation on totally independent MSK data just
published this year, totally more than 50,000 cancer
samples. But eventually, after use different rules, for
example, OncoTree mapping, remove multi-sample
patients, eventually we have over 12,000 samples used
to do the validation.
As a result, top one accuracy close over
62% compare our original 77% internally.
Top three was 82% compared to 93
internally.
I know there's a 15-point gap, but I think it's kind of
expected. There was three things at least changed
automatically. So it's a different sequencing platform, it's a
different gene panel, and a totally different patients
population from West and Eastern.
But we do observe some key confuse.
For example, small cell lung cancer compared to HCC,
cervical versus breast cancer. We need to solve this problem in
the next training cycle.
So the limitation part. So clearly our training cohort
was predominant Chinese patient.
Luckily, MSK data set demonstrated this
robustness partially, but still we need more data to do the
extension. Currently, we only cover 19 cancer types,
so hopefully we can have a better result performance
on even more cancer types in the retraining.
But there's an issue, for example, we put a single KRAS
G12C to any prediction, is not possible to give a
unique result anyway. This is really a biological ceiling for
all the prediction.
So we use top five output with a different confidence level.
So if it's a too low confidence score, we'll trigger the real
tumor
board.
So there's also a class imbalance between us because, for example, in the
training set, you have one large major type, has too much example, we
try to balance with minor cancer types.
But eventually,
CUB AI 2 was designed as a decision
support, but not complete replacement.
It cannot be used as standalone tool for diagnosis, even
for CUB.
So come to the conclusion. So NGS is a standard in
oncology. Every cancer patient with existing NGS
report carry raw material for molecular second opinion
already. So from our opinion, so all the cancer patient with NGS
report should do a prediction.So CAPI AI 2 is a
one step to that direction. By using the NGS data,
it will predict the primary site to help doctor make a decision,
but clearly, this is not a standalone tool for any situation.
So right now, CAPI AI cover only 19 cancer types, is
granting the database like 100,000 cancer patients,
has a paired clinical genomic data.
So we're trying to increase the data set, also include more cancer type
together.
We did a reasonable validation on independent data set
from MSK. We're working more on the external data to do
the furthermore performance improvement.
So,
put them together, actually right now, this is not just in a series.
So CAPI AI 1, the first generation, has been used in our
eHospital for years, because CAPI AI 1
was developed four years back, has been used on thousands of
cancer patients from our eHospital already.
So next, we're trying to increase cancer type, also
deploy the CAPI AI integration into our eHospital, the
full workflows.
So I'd like to thank all the patients, the co-author, Dr.
Zhao, and my colleagues at OrigMed, and also, there's
a open source MSK data CBio portal teams too.
There's a contact information, our website, and follow our new
update for our program. Thank you. Question welcome.
Well, if anybody's interested in asking a question, please go up to
the mics that are sort of in the middle there.
Anyway, thanks very much for sticking perfectly to time.
So we have one question there. Sure.
Hey, great talk.
I have just a question on interpretability.
So were you able to see molecular differences in the
original training cohort versus the MSK cohort?
You mean the reason why we're seeing the difference?
Yeah.
All the training data are from Chinese
patient. We know some cancer, they do have a very different
genomic profiling. For example, EGFR were found more common
in Chinese, but not Western people. KRAS in the other hand.
So I think that's one of the reason, because our model never seen the training data
like that, may give us some wrong answer.
But like I'm showing from the slides, like squamous cell lung cancer, we're
trying to figure out why they are going to miss the result with HCC.
We haven't figured out yet.
But put them together, as I said, simultaneously, not only the sequencing
panel, but also the gene size, population, all change.
I think this almost the 70% is reasonable from
our perspective.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah. Thank you.
Hi, I have question about this. How model potentially
handle different modality data. For example, you only have the NGS
data. If you have RNA-seq data, or
even imaging data, then your model will take this multimodality data
as input, give you a better prediction.
Yeah. That's exactly the future direction. Good question.
Also, as I mentioned, so you can imagine if there's only
KRAS G12C, you put it in the predictor, it can't
tell you anything about the primary site, because it's just
too less information. There's lots of those options on the list.
So we always recommend doctor to use different results of
the material, like you mentioned, H&E image, other
test, IHC. I think put them together should be much more
better on performance. But currently, I think for NGS,
anyway, NGS report is becoming more and more standard in clinic.
So we just hope from this simple tool, people can start to use it
to prediction as a second opinion, but eventually, you can't use this as
a standalone decision diagnosis.
You still need to combine all the information together as a real molecular tumor
board.
Yeah.
Okay, well, I have a question. So, probably
applicable to a lot of machine learning approaches is how does
one convince your clinical colleagues that this black
box is really going to tell them something useful and that
they'll believe it? Because it sounds like you've already managed that with
CAPI AI 1, and you're doing it with CAPI AI 2.
Maybe you could elaborate how you managed to make that transition.
Yeah. That's a really good question.
Actually,
so
as I said, we are eHospital. We have doctors seeing patients
online. CAPI AI 1 has been used for a few years.
From my personal experience,
I can't leave it to do the work. So,
it will give me the information right away, and also the new update, what
we can do to distinguish of this disease to the other.
I think it's very, very helpful. I know some AI tools is not
really being seen value from a clinic yet, but like this
small tool, only from the NGS results, I think is really give you
a background information, what could be the disease is, I think is
currently is very valuable.
Nice.
Yeah.
Okay, well, if there's no more questions, do you have one?
No.
No. Then let's thank Kai again.
Thank you.
Okay, so we are right on time. Next we have
Akshat Singhal from UC San Diego, Multisite
Analysis of a Deep Learning Model for Prediction of, I hope I'm
pronouncing it right, Palbociclib
Response in Patients With ER Positive, HER2 Negative Advanced
Breast Cancer.
Hi, everyone. Thanks for being here, and thanks the organizer and the
chairs for giving me this chance to present our work
on
a retrospective study of a deep learning model to predict
palbociclib response in patients with ER positive, HER2 negative advanced breast
cancer.So just a quick update on my affiliation.
I recently joined City of Hope as a postdoc.
But I'm happy to see colleagues old and new here.
Okay, these are my disclosures.
Yeah. So
machine learning in precision oncology deals with
collecting all possible information of a patient, be
genotype, clinical, or radiographic images, using
a machine learning model to predict some outcome like drug response,
toxicity, or cancer progression.
In my work, I primarily develop drug
response prediction models where the input is a tumor
genotype. As Kai mentioned earlier, it's like NGS profile,
which contains
alterations, copy numbers, and mutations.
And then we use a machine learning model to predict treatment outcome.
The goal of these models is to stratify patients
into responders and non-responders and,
along with that, identify biomarkers, which are
biological indicators of response, like mutations,
signatures, or pathways.
In the last 10 years in particular, we have seen a tremendous growth in drug
response prediction models, especially because of data availability and
modeling techniques. However, this
translation to the clinics has not happened yet, and there are only a
handful
models that have made it to clinical evaluation.
So what is the reason for this gap in translation from
computation to clinic? And talks in
the conference have mentioned a lot of points. I'll just go over two of them.
The first being evaluation. Have we tested the model
properly, well enough on clinical data?
And the second is interpretation.
Are we able to scrutinize the inner workings of a model to
identify these potential biomarkers?
So
let's look at the drug response model we are going to
evaluate, or we have evaluated in our work.
I'm going to start with the data.
This model was previously trained and published using
tumor cell lines across 900 cell lines
on 718 genes from
multiple clinical gene panels. In this work, we
have tested this model on two clinical cohorts,
and I'll go over those in detail later.
The architecture for this model was a deep neural network.
I should point out that choosing the correct architecture
is very closely related to interpretability.
In our case, or for this model, we achieved
interpretability by mapping each
neuron to some biological entity.
In this case, each entity is this node is
either a protein complex, which combines to form
pathways, organelles, all the way up to the cell.
So guiding this architecture through this hierarchical map of
protein clusters really gives us insight into how
a model is working. We call this architecture a visible neural
network or VNN.
So the last point is,
or the last part of the model is our drug of interest.
In this case, we trained the model on palbociclib,
which is a CDK4/6 inhibitor. CDK4 and
CDK6 regulate cell cycle
by phosphorylating Rb, which allows cell cycle progression.
And palbociclib, along with endocrine therapy, is a standard of
care in ER-positive, HER2-negative advanced breast cancer and has markedly
changed patient outcome. However, the response rate
hovers around 50%, and there are no clinical biomarkers
of palbociclib response yet. So there's this unmet need
in clinical care.
So to address-- Oh, maybe we can just go back.
To address this
gap, we,
other authors at UCSD, we developed this model of palbociclib
response. But at the time of publication, we did not
have patient data that contained progression-free survival
information for palbociclib. And so we decided to
do a further evaluation of the model, and the first
dataset for this evaluation was from
UCSD Moores Cancer Center.
My co-authors, Dr. Zui Zhang, Dr. Kei Yung, among others,
collected clinical and
genomic information for 139 patients.
But as I mentioned, because one of the main aims was to really
assess the model on progression-free survival, they also
manually calculated PFS
for all patients treated in first-line treatment.
And we further
filtered out the patients
based on their NGS. So their NGS was done 180 days
before up to 90 days after the start of treatment.
And what we see is
the model, the PalboVNN model, was able to stratify
patients into sensitive and resistant cohorts with a significant
hazard ratio of 0.38, with a difference of
median progression of about 14 months.
However, all the filters
reduced the number of patient samples to 36.
So to augment this number, we utilized another
cohort, also from MSK. Thank you. So MSK cohort
data was released recently, and
we were able to acquire data for about 474 patients,
even after all the filters. And so we saw
that
even for the bigger cohort, PalboVNN was able to stratify
patients
into sensitive and resistant subgroups.
This time, although the hazard ratio was not as good,
but it was still significant, and we see a
median progression difference of 18
months.But very
interestingly, what we were also able to see was that
PabloVNN was specific to palbociclib
treatment. Here I'm showing you two plots.
On the left, you see this cohort treated with palbociclib
with letrozole, which is an endocrine partner.
On the right, you see patients treated only with letrozole.
And on the left, we can see that
these patients were significantly stratified, but not
the case for letrozole only. And we see that regardless
of the endocrine partner. So even for fulvestrant, we're able to see that
the model was able to stratify patients treated with palbo plus
fulvestrant, but not fulvestrant only.
Okay. So after evaluation, we moved on to model
interpretation.
And across the two cohorts, we are able to see 18 protein
assemblies being important for model prediction,
where 11 were shared across both cohorts.
And these assemblies captured diverse mechanisms such as
cytoskeleton, DNA integrity, and cell cycle checkpoints,
histone modification, AKT active and signaling, among others.
But more than that, we were able to look at the inner workings
of the model for individual patients.
So here I'm showing you one report.
We tried to make a report for each patient.
So here I'm showing you a report for a patient from UCSD, who,
during the time of
data collection, was still under treatment and so had a very durable response
to palbociclib. And the model was correctly able to predict
this response. The score of 20 is normalized, and so
it's a strongly sensitive patient according to the model.
But more than that, we are able to see what are the factors affecting the
response. So we see a wild type RB1 and
p53 and amplifications in FGF3 and
4 being strongly driving the response
prediction. Among the assemblies, we see DNA integrity
and cell cycle checkpoints and transmembrane RTK signaling as being
the important factors.
For another patient,
who was
not responding to palbociclib, had a PFS of three months
and an overall survival of 18 months, the model was
correctly able to predict a strongly resistant response with a
score of 79. In this case, the patient had a lot of mutations,
with ROS1 being the most
influential in predicting resistance.
The assemblies
were cytoskeleton and adherens junction, among others.
I'm just showing you a small
outcome from the bigger picture.
Okay. So, to summarize. PabloVNN can
extract information from limited genomic features from
NGS and can harness the knowledge of hallmark cancer
pathways to predict palbociclib response.
Machine learning models should be rigorously assessed in high-stakes
clinical applications, and prospective studies are
warranted for further evaluation.
On that note, I'm also very happy to share that we were able to
start a phase two prospective trial here at Moores Cancer Center,
and we just got data for our first patient last night, so
fingers crossed. And finally, I would like to thank all the co-authors,
especially Drs. Ruoyi Zhang, Dr. Kei Yung, and Dr.
Tri-Dekker, and all our funding sources. Thank you.
Great. Questions, if you can.
I'll start with one question. So when you're using
MSK, I assume it's a targeted panel?
Yeah. It's the MSK-IMPACT panel of either 468 genes
or 515 genes, whatever is available from the data. Yeah.
So how do you correct for differences in presence of
protein assemblies between something that is a whole genome or a whole
exome and targeted panels?
So this model was trained only on information from targeted
panels.
Mm.
And we just look at whatever mutations or copy numbers are available,
and we just put it in the model. Yeah.
Great. Thank you.
No questions?
Other questions?
I can ask another question. So did you test the
model on other CDK inhibitors?
Oh, yeah. So from the MSK cohort, we were able to extract some
information for
ribociclib and
abemaciclib. Maybe I can... Oh, sorry.
I don't have my exercise. But for ribociclib,
the model was able to give a quite striking
prediction. The stratification was highly effective.
For abemaciclib, the response was less strong,
but it was still able to stratify patients with a decent difference in
median progression.
Great.
Yeah. So Samanti Mukherjee from Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer
Center. I have a question about great work, but how do you deal
with those ancestry and the different proportion of the
somatic mutation? Do you have it in your model?
Yeah, that's a great question. So right now, we are not looking at clinical
background or information from clinical histories.
This is something that's an ongoing work.
Hopefully, we'll be able to include those.
But so far, the model only looks at mutations and copy
number alterations from NGS panels.
Do you expect any change in the prediction?
Oh yeah, absolutely. I think clinical features are super
important. There are so many,
just if nothing else, like comorbidities and all that are going to
affect a treatment outcome.
Thank you.
Thanks.
I have a brief question. You maybe mentioned this at the beginning, but
in regards to the patients, is that from a biopsy, a blood
sample?
How much DNA do you need?
Yeah. Thank you. Yeah, that was a good question. I think I missed that.
So these are all data collected from biopsy samples.
I did test, this is unpublished work.
I did test the model on liquid biopsy data.
The signal is much lower.
The model can work because it's trained on such sparse data, but I haven't done
an
ample amount of research or evaluation there. Yeah.
But there's potential there.
There's potential there, yes.
Nice.
I have a quick question related to Sandy's.
So are the
biopsies from the primary or from the
metastasis? If you have both, do you see any difference
in the prediction
accuracy?
Sorry, could you please repeat the question?
So I'm asking if you have
the molecular data from the primary tumor or from the
metastasis.
So, for the UCSD cohort, I think it was
all primary tumors, but in the MSK cohort, it was both
primary and metastatic. I think I filtered for
only metastatic, if I'm not sure. But yeah, there are samples from both,
and the model works on either. Yeah.
Thank you.
Thanks again.
Okay, next up we have
Hui Xu, who's going to talk to us about OncoTwin,
a multimodal digital twin framework for predicting
treatment response and guiding trial design in
ALK-rearranged non-small cell lung cancer.
Intriguing.
Take it away.
Thank
you for the introduction. On behalf of my co-authors, it's
my honor to present our recent work
on OncoTwin, a multimodal digital twin
framework for predicting treatment response and
guiding trial design in ALK-rearranged non-small cell lung
cancer. My name is Xu Hui from MD Anderson Cancer
Center.
I have no conflicts of interest to disclose.
First, I want to introduce our BrightStar clinical trial, which
is a phase 2 clinical trial to evaluate the flexibility,
safety, and efficacy of integrating local
consolidation therapy with brigatinib compared with
brigatinib alone in TKI naive or ALK-rearranged
non-small cell lung cancer.
The right panel is the observed progression-free
survival of BrightStar trial. The median PFS is
around 66 months. The survival looks good,
but
since it's a single-arm clinical trial, how do we know the
ALCT benefit or not?
When we extend to all these kinds of single-arm clinical trial,
we miss the control arm. How can we quantify the trial
results? In this work, we aim to solve this issue.
Real-world data always holds great potential to support clinical
trial evidence. Our GEMINI database contains over
16,000 lung cancer patients. Applying
eligibility criteria, we finally identified
103 ALK-rearranged patients from our
real-world database. Crucially, we know none of these
patients received ALCT.
We used these patients to build a prognostic model, then
applied the model to BrightStar trial to estimate these
patients' outcome without ALCT. Since we
simulated the counterfactual trajectory of the exact same
trial patients, we call this a digital twin.
Here we outline our data collection and modeling
framework. We collected the whole body CT images
for panel routine blood test from
both baseline and post-induction time points.
From CT images, we performed whole body 3D annotation
lesion by lesion, and labeled the lesion location also.
The corresponding delta features were also calculated.
Except for these features, we also collected some clinical ready data,
including 2D sum of the longest diameter, we will name
SLD later, TKI type, and clinical demographic
features. By leveraging this data, we constructed two
models. The first, 2D model uses
only clinical ready variables, including
2D SLD, TKI type, and clinical features, making it
straightforward to implement in clinical practice.
The second, 3D model is more comprehensive, incorporating
3D longitudinal whole body tumor burden, longitudinal
routine blood tests, TKI type, and clinical features,
offering a granular characterization of each
patient.We used a hold out
five-fold independent test
scheme to test the prognosis performance of
OncoTwin 2D model. Our results show OncoTwin
2D can realize risk stratification with
significance in overall cohorts.
However, in different TKI
generation subgroups, it holds potential but didn't reach
the statistical significance.
Using the same evaluation strategy, OncoTwin 3D
model achieved a significant risk stratification in both the overall
cohort and each TKI generation subgroup,
demonstrating superior prognostic performance over the 2D model.
Beyond the risk stratification, we further validated our
model's prognosis simulation capability on the OTA-1L
trial cohort.
OTA-1L is a phase III trial comparing two
TKI generations, crizotinib versus
brigatinib, in all career range of lung cancer.
Its long-term results demonstrated a significantly better
progression-free survival with brigatinib.
These trial results were published in the "New England Journal"
in 2018, leading to FDA approval of
brigatinib as the first-line standard of care for all career
range of non-small cell lung cancer.
Applying OncoTwin 2D to the OTA-1L patients, the
model simulated survival closely matched to the observed
trial outcome with no significance in both two
TKI subgroups. That confirms OncoTwin 2D
can replicate the real clinical trial survivals despite the model
is simple.
Building on the successful validation of 2D model, we now
use OncoTwin 3D model and return to the BrightStar
trial to answer our original questions.
Is LCT effective in this single-arm setting?
BrightStar trial totally enrolled 34 patients.
The left table is the patients' baseline characteristics,
of whom 32 received LCT. We applied
OncoTwin 3D to simulate each patient's prognosis
without LCT, directly answering what would have happened to
these patients if they didn't receive LCT.
This allows us to synthesize a natural control arm using the
exact same 32 patients.
Comparing the simulated and observed survival, looking at the
survival curve of the right panel, we found a
significant difference. The solid curve is the actually
observed survival of the trial patients.
The dashed curve is the digital twin simulated survival
without LCT. The results shows a significant
survival benefit with hazard ratio around 2.8
and the log-rank p is significant.
We can therefore answer the clinical questions with more confidence, LCT
should be effective.
But you may ask, how do we know the simulated outcomes are reliable?
To validate this, we performed a propensity score matching using the
OTA-1L cohort. The
propensity score matching derived hazard ratio closely matched our
digital twin estimate,
indirectly confirming the reliability of our synthetic control
arm. However, while our propensity score matching can provide
the supportive evidence for single-arm trial, it has
several limitations, such as
unmeasured confounding bias, group level
inference only, and lack of standardization.
We further show an example in the right panel.
These two patients, they have similar clinical
characterizations, but their outcomes were totally different.
The right side patient progressed within
five months, while the left side patient remained
progression free for over 16 months.
But our digital twin model can capture this heterogeneity,
enable
early clinical insights and provided individual outcome prediction.
We further compare traditional random control trial,
propensity score matching, and digital twin as control arm strategies.
Random control trial is the golden standard but is
slow, expensive, and hard to generalize to real-world
patients. Propensity score matching is more practical but is
still limited by covariate bias and
only for group level inference. The digital twin overcomes
both, is fast, cost efficient, and
allows individual prediction, making it the most viable
approach for single-arm trials.
Beyond the control arm simulation, the digital twin has other
applications including individual survival trajectory
prediction,
individual treatment effect estimation, and using
simulation-based resampling to assess patient
enrollment size, which could support the design of next
phase trial.
In conclusion, we introduced a digital twin framework
that models individual treatment trajectories use
multimodal data in all career range of the lung small cell lung
cancer. Its application in the phase II BrightStar trial
demonstrated how retrospective real-world data can
inform prospective trial design through AI model.
Also, this framework serves as a blueprint extensible to
other cancer types.
Finally, I would like to acknowledge and thank
our multidisciplinary team, collaborators, patients,
and funding. In particular, I would like to thank my PI, Dr.
Jia Wu and John Hemak for leading this project.
And yeah, thank you. I'm happy to take any questions.
And for potential collaborations, please feel free to reach out by email.
Thank you.
Okay. We have plenty of time for questions if anybody would like to ask
one.
Great talks. Thank you. So I wonder,
can you explain the difference between your digital twin model and the
mechanism-based digital twin model?
Okay. Thank you. Thank you for your question.
How to say?
As far as I know,
mechanism-based digital twins, they are
different. I think mechanism-based digital twin
relied on
biological or physical equations.
They have some
prior hypothesis,
such as, I know some tumor growth model or PD
or PK model like this. And for our digital
twin model, we are data-driven directly.
We are directly learning the information from the real-world
database.
But
I think
these two methods, they can
be complementary.
We can try to leverage the
advantage of both strategies.
We can use the
biological interpretability of
the
mechanism-based digital twin. And
we can also
use some machine learning-based
things from our digital twin model.
We can learn directly information from
our real-world large dataset. Yeah.
It's a
good question, and
currently, we are actively
exploring more strategies to combine
both and to build more practical digital twin for
our work in the future. Thank you for your question.
Thank you. So another question is, in your
presentation,
you mentioned the OncoTWIN
2D and OncoD 3D model, right?
So
I want to ask what's the difference between them, and
what's the rationale for you to develop these two
models?
Yeah. 2D model
is our original rationale. We
think it's easy to clinical because we only use
several very basic features.
And the 3D model is more accurate, but it is labor
intensive. Yeah, we need to do the manual
annotation based on the images.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay. While we wait for someone else to ask a question, I'm going to ask one.
So that was very nice. I guess one of the things that I think seems really
important here is this idea of a synthetic control
that you can actually match
the predictions of the outcome of the trial with a control that's
treated to the exact same patient in some sense, right?
But have you looked at how that worked?
How does your synthetic control compare to randomized
studies where there's a control built in, right?
Have you looked at the variance there?
Do you match their control, or do you predict something different
with your control?
Could you
repeat your questions?
Repeat your question?
Oh, repeat my question. No, I'm just basically saying,
you can produce a
synthetic control.
Yes.
Right?
Yeah. Right.
But that's because you match the trial outcome with your own
twin.
Yeah.
Right?
We do the merge. Yeah.
So in a randomized study, they will have a
randomized control.
Yes.
How does your synthetic control compare to
the randomized control?
To the randomized control?
Yes.
First, we think the randomized control is
clinical golden, but
we haven't the randomized control arm.
So that is the current issue, right?
For single arm settings,
it's an issue. And between the propensity score matching and
our digital twins, right?
Yeah.
Propensity score matching is,
they can
only invest several clinical basic features
to matching the patients if they are the pair.
Like we show in that examples, the
two patients, they have very similar clinical characteristics.
Yeah.
When we do the propensity score matching, they can be a pair.
But they are different. Their prognoses are totally different.
Yeah.
But in our digital twin, we used more features, such as we
used the
longitudinal whole body tumor burden
measurements, and we used some blood test features.
And these features can-provided a more
comprehensive character for patients.
So applied to the model, if we have
all of these features, we can give the patients maybe more
accurate
prognosis prediction like this.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm not sure. I'll directly ask your question.
We can talk about it after. You didn't quite answer.
But one other small question there is-
Uh-huh
... I'm someone who builds those mechanistic digital twins.
One of the things that we use a lot is dynamic data, so like
temporal biomarkers of different aspects of their disease.
Does this OncoTwin integrate more dynamic temporal data,
or can it?
More dynamic?
So imagine like a blood biomarker, for example-
Uh-huh
... in ovarian cancer, CA 125, in prostate
cancer, PSA.
You could get multiple measures over time, which also could be
integrated. We use those sorts of things in digital twins
and mechanistic models.
We didn't.
We only use a routine blood test.
Sure.
Yeah. We didn't touch that. Yeah.
Okay, we have one question on the floor.
Okay, thank you. Go ahead.
Thank you for the great presentation.
My question is that it seems you are using the
twins and trying to improve the future clinical
trial design.
From the designing perspective, which part of the
designing you think that your study will bring the best benefit?
For example, is that providing the
control arm, or the timing of the treatment that you're going to
find or the eligibility? Could you comment a little bit on that?
Thank you.
Yeah. Could you-- Sorry, could you like-
Don't worry. I was thinking
to improve the future designing of the-
Mm-hmm
... clinical trial, what do you think your study
will benefit the most? Which part of the
designing your study is going to benefit
the most?
Yes.
In future trial design, the first
thing is,
if you designed a single arm trial, we can
simulate, we can synthetic a control arm
that is directly maybe used for your future
trial design. Another thing is
we used some
resampling-based
things to estimate how many patients you
will to enrolled in your next
phase trial. Because we show just in a figure
that when you improved, how many patients
you have to improve. You need to improve, you can reach the
stable or powerful trial results.
Like here, is that we
give to indicate for the next
trial design. I hope this answers your question.
Yes. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Okay. Thanks again.
Right. So next we have Chintan Parmar, from
AstraZeneca.
"AI-derived H&E biomarkers predict differential
survival under immunotherapy versus chemotherapy in phase III
metastatic non-small cell lung cancer study NEPTUNE."
Thank you,
ACR and chairs for giving this opportunity
to share our work, and good afternoon, everyone.
So yeah. I'm going to share a work on how we are
leveraging AI to derive
spatial insights which are interpretable,
in order to investigate whether these insights could
enhance further clinical trial stratifications in
particularly for immunotherapy.
This is, as you can see, these are my co-authors, and I would like to
thank and acknowledge them.
This is a big collaborative effort across many folks
in AstraZeneca, coming from translation medicine,
clinical teams,
as well as AI and data science teams.
These are my disclosures. Just wanted to mention that the study we are
analyzing in this investigation retrospectively,
is NEPTUNE, which is sponsored by AstraZeneca.
So to start with the clinical motivation,
in metastatic NSCLC,
response to immunotherapy
is highly variable.
And one of the main challenges to identify who actually
benefits these treatments. There are widely
used markers, like PDL1 score and TMB scores,
but they are not sufficient enough to reliably identify
a right set of patients who can actually benefit.
So we think there is an opportunity for using
H&Es here.
Why we think H&Es is one of the vital modality to go
after is because H&Es is already integrated in
clinical workflows. So these data already exist,
and these images can be readily be available to
analyze them. The other aspect is that H&Es
capture spatial architectures of a tumor
microenvironment, which we
believe is fundamentally linked to immune response.
So there is a universally available
data modality, and there is a way to extract insights
from that. So our approach is
simple. We want to use AITo extract
spatial interpretable features
from these H&Es, and then we want to assess
whether these features can associate with outcome and whether
they can improve the existing patient stratifications
in these different clinical trials.
So the central hypothesis is that, yes, these spatial insights
are relevant and can enhance patient stratification and trial enrichment.
So to test this, we focused on Neptune
study. Neptune was a phase three first-line
metastatic NSCLC study.
The study had two arms, an IO combination arm,
and there was a chemotherapy control arm.
The study did not meet its primary endpoint, which was
a significant overall survival benefit in high TMB group,
although the trend was
very strong. And this again highlights
the point I was referring earlier,
that the challenge related to sort of finding the right set of
patients for right treatment.
And we also felt that this is an ideal study to
investigate that these types of
AI-derived H&E markers
could or would have added any additional sort of
insights
to TMB scores or PDL1 scores, which were
primarily used for stratifying patients in this
study.
So
we went back retrospectively and selected
images from the study.
These images were ethically reviewed and made sure that we are
only using data that we are compliant to use for.
So that resulted in around 468 H&E images from
the study.
After excluding images for quality reasons
and keeping
one unique image per
case or per patient,
the resultant number was around 426.
So 154 out of these 426 were coming from IO arm,
272 were coming from chemo arm.
The table indicates the baseline patient characteristics here.
We did not see any significant difference in these characteristics between the
arms, which suggests that any
confounding effect for these types of characteristics are
likely to be minimal for the investigation.
So our approach, as I mentioned earlier, is simple.
We want to leverage AI at scale to derive
spatial insights that are interpretable and grounded in
biology,
and then try to investigate whether they are relevant for
associating with outcome and stratifying patients.
So to do that, we leveraged
Path Explorer, which is a product from PathAI.
Essentially these are AI-powered
pathology models that are trained using
around 6,000 annotated whole slide images.
Just to emphasize that these models are trained completely
independently from any of the images that are used
in this study
or per se also
prior to this investigation. So these models were just
like in an off-the-shelf manner, were taken and then deployed on these
images and the data was generated.
The models essentially segment different tissue and
cell regions in the tumor microenvironment and then
quantitatively
generate the features which would describe densities and spatial
relationships of these substances on H&Es.
So for the analysis, we focused on 15
simple features that are interpretable related to spatial
relationships and densities of immune cells, fibroblasts,
and tumor cells, because we think that those are the features that are likely to be
relevant for immunoresponse.
Immune cells here refer to a composite measure of lymphocyte,
macrophages, and plasma cells.
So now coming to key results, what we observed is
that these features can stratify patients,
and we noticed a significant differential
overall survival groups between the high and low groups of
these features. The high and low groups were decided based on just
a median cutoffs.
So as you can notice that AI-derived fibroblast phenotype
significantly separated patients in terms of overall
survival in IO arm as well as in the chemo arm.
One other thing you would notice is that this association is negatively
associated with the outcome here.
So more fibroblasts meaning worse overall
survival. On the other hand, when we looked at the immune
phenotype derived using these models, what we noticed is that there is a
predictive trend here, and we noticed that the association
and the differential
overall survival was observed in the IO arm, but not in the
chemo arm. Moreover, when we tried to univariate compare
these features to some of the other
clinical markers, including PDL1, TMB, as well as
age, gender,
race,
et cetera, we noticed that these features perform
competitively or even better in most of the cases
than these existing markers. So these all indicate that
there is a potential of these features adding values
to the existing markers and potentially enhancing
the patient
stratification.Then we asked that, okay,
how do they do together in a multivariate manner?
So what we did is in the IOM, we
trained up a multivariate Cox model and did an out-of-fold
validation by iteratively using
only clinical and demographic features by adding PD-L1 and TMB
score into this model, as well as by adding H&E features here.
And what we noticed is that when we added
the H&E-based features,
the separation was significant, which wasn't the case
otherwise. The right table also indicates
survival percentages at six-month interval.
The other thing important to note is that
at 18 months interval,
the event rate distributions between
high and low risk group
for this particular model was around 21%.
So which again, suggests the practical implications that
these kinds of features could potentially enrich
a high-risk group
subset of patients and that might be valuable for event-driven
IO trials.
So in summary, I would conclude with mainly four
take-home messages.
One being that these spatial features have
complementary value to PD-L1 and TMB, which are routinely used
currently. We noticed prognostic trend for
fibroblast-related phenotype and predictive trend for
immune-related phenotype.
These
observations have potential for
enhancing patient stratification and
enriching
patient selection.
And the next steps is, again, all of this is done in a
retrospective setting in this particular cohort.
So
the next step should be that these findings, if they can be validated
prospectively,
then there is a way for these types of approaches to translate into
clinical utility. So with that, I will
conclude and I'll be ready for questions. Thank you.
Chintan. Mike Seracci. Fantastic talk as always. Thank you, sir.
So when you think about the rate limiters of the
performance of pulling these types of features out of H&Es,
and you know the data set that you had in your hands very well,
do you think that the
number of samples or the information
actually contained within the images is more
of a, I guess, a primary rate limiter, and those are the
two that come to mind?
What leads and then what else, I think is-
Sorry, Mike, I couldn't hear you. The number of images?
Do you think it's the N or do you think it's the information actually
contained within the H&Es or are there other rate limiters?
So how much better can this get from the H&E?
Yeah, no, that's a great question.
So I think it's probably both.
When we are looking at clinical associations, I think numbers matter.
So that will give you more events and then more effect sizes.
In terms of information
alone existing in
H&Es, I think these are pretty gigantic images.
So if you look at the pixel
level information, there is ton of data even just in one slide.
So depending upon what sort of morphology you are trying to model
or use, you could consider the number
game accordingly. So, if your goal is to
perfect any particular morphologic trait that you want to model and capture from
using your models, then there is enough data that you can
generate from even limited number of H&Es.
Having said that, if the goal is the clinical-grade predictions, then you will
need the outcome data and the sample representations
accordingly.
Of course. Look forward to your future work. Thank you.
Thank you.
Great talk. Thank you.
I'm Gabriel Furingane. I'm from Cambridge, UK.
Quick questions regarding the informations that it is
containing in the images. Do you think that with advanced
foundation models, you can extract more of that information?
And even with that, do you think that
we'll need more biologically informed fine-tuning to extract the
right information from the images?
Thank you. Yeah, that's a great question.
So there are some excellent sessions around
foundation models and their utilities.
So,
the short answer is yes. But the way I think about this
is that
there's definitely a
tech
advantage of using foundation models.
Because certainly with foundation models, these kinds of
models are likely to be more efficient,
faster to develop. They'll also turn out to be
more robust because of the gigantic cohort sizes that foundation models
usually have seen. In terms of whether
those
foundation models would be-- I believe your second part was regarding
interpretation, right?
Yes.
Yeah. So whether you go for interpretable approaches
or
data-driven abstract feature space approaches, I think
it could
vary on use case to use case. I feel
likeIntuitively, you would want to go for the most
optimal approach. Having said that, anything that needs to be sort
of used for clinical decisions or influence
would need some level of interpretability or
explainability. So you could consider that these kinds of features are easy to
interpret and hence easy to explain it to clinicians and hence sort
of use it in clinic.
If foundation models are significantly optimal
or better than these models, then you could consider even using them together,
where you build a predictor using foundation models and then use
these types of model to sort of look at that, okay,
wherever the higher tension regions within foundation models are, what are the
underlying sort of tumor microenvironment looking like, what sort of cells are
there,
and then try to sort of interpret the model performance accordingly.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm curious about the immune inflamed phenotype and whether you think
being able to parse out the different immune cell types,
A, is that even possible by H&E? Because some of those might have
positive versus negative prognostic implications.
And then if it's not, do you think that being able to
understand those immune phenotypes could improve a model like this?
Yeah. So in my experience, we do see
immune phenotype being consistent across different studies.
So like all these immune cells, usually the higher the densities
are, the better generally is the response
or the survival rates. So I have
personally seen that in some of the investigations that I've done, but
all those things have also been thoroughly published.
And
many such investigations have shown that from H&Es
and
different kinds of immune phenotypes can be extracted that are
associated with outcome and how they are also associated with the other
multimodal data like other immune gene signatures,
et cetera. So I think this is sort of
the ongoing work in the field, but there are evidences which
suggest that.
All right, thanks.
Thank you.
Okay, thanks again.
Okay, next up we have Pahini Pandya.
She's coming to us from Cambridge in the UK, and
she's going to tell us about
a translational deep learning platform predicts metabolic
pathway activity from routine H&E slides to enable
patient stratification.
Thank you. Hello, everyone.
I'm Pahini, and on behalf of my co-authors, it's my pleasure to present
our study on a translational deep learning platform
on predicting metabolic pathway activity from routine H&E stained
images for patient stratification.
These are my conflicts of interest.
Metabolic reprogramming is a well-established hallmark of cancer.
As a result, it's an active area of drug development with several
programs targeting altered metabolic pathways.
Despite significant progress, there remains still a critical gap in
reliable, scalable assessment of tumor metabolic states
primarily because metabolic profiling requires
specialized handling, workflows, availability of fresh tissue, and
is associated with significant cost, which limits its
utility in large-scale screening and clinical
trials, eventually limiting its translation to the
clinical settings. So we set out to address this gap
and began with a simple hypothesis that was based on prior
work done by myself and colleagues, where we had demonstrated that
altered metabolic activity results in cell and tissue
morphology changes. We hypothesized off the back of that, that
deep learning could exploit these morphological changes
to infer pathway-level functional states from routine H&E.
The study involved three steps. The first step was
establishing the ground truth, which was
encapsulated as personalized genome-scale
metabolic models that were derived from TCGA transcriptomics
data. This was what was then used to train our deep learning
platform, specifically models that would be able to
predict metabolic activity, so enrichment or
otherwise, as binary predictions directly from H&E
images. So let me go a bit deeper in terms of how we
approached the ground truth establishment and training of our models.
In terms of the ground truth, we assessed 32 metabolic pathways
across 21 cancer types available in the TCGA datasets.
In order to get to the pathway activity, we derived
personalized genome-scale metabolic models or metabolic models
using transcriptomics data. These were accessed via
studies published by Uhler et al. in 2017,
and our models, which are publicly available via the EBI BioModels
Repository. We had access to personalized genome-scale
models for 6,700 patients,
which we then used and compared against a baseline also available
in the same repository, and conducted a gene set enrichment
analysis in order to identify genes which were enriched,
associated with specific metabolic pathways.
We conducted hypergeometric tests with
Benjamini-Hochberg corrections and a false discovery rate
of less than 0.05,
and compressed all of the outputs into
binarized outputs indicating whether the metabolite pathway was
enriched or not enriched. These binary
outputs for each individual cancer, for each
individual patient, were what we used to train our deep learning
models, which included a ResNet 34 encoder paired with a
decoder and a classifier head.These models were
trained on tiles of 256 by 256 pixels
derived from H&E stained whole slide images representative
for that individual patient
with combined cross-entropy loss and
reconstruction loss.
We then conducted a threefold cross-validation where
we fixed each individual patient's per
cancer to a specific fold in order to
avoid any cross-contamination. The cohort sizes varied from
53 to 887 whole slide images
per metabolic pathway, depending on cancer type.
And we used mean area under the curve as our measurement metrics
for predictability of these biomarkers from H&E.
So what did we find?
Well, of the 21 cancer types that we evaluated, we ended up with
450 pathway cancer pair models
that were tested. Of these, 87% had
AUCs of more than 0.5, indicating some degree of
predictability from H&E, as can be seen in the scatter
plot at the bottom half of the slide.
The different colors of the dot indicate different pathways,
as indicated by the legend on the bottom right-hand side of the plot.
What was interesting was that we noticed
9% of these pathways had very high
predictability with mean AUCs of greater than 0.65, as
can be seen in the data points within this
encapsulating box.
Furthermore, we noticed that there was a clustering of specific
metabolic pathway types with high levels of predictability, including
nucleotide synthesis,
nuclear transport, and mitochondrial transport pathways, as well as fatty
acid beta-oxidation pathway, as indicated by the clustering of the colored
dots here.
Zooming into the top 10 pathways, we noticed that the
AUCs range from 0.71 going up to 0.85,
with top performance for nucleotide metabolism, including
0.85 AUC for testicular germline cell
cancers and 0.79 AUCs for pancreatic
cancer. This was followed by transport mechanism, including
AUCs of 0.79 for colorectal adenocarcinoma
for nuclear transport and 0.77 for ovarian
cancers for mitochondrial transports.
So why is this important? Four reasons. First, drug discovery.
Such pan-cancer metabolic profiling can reveal
cross-functional pathway dependencies, the exact type of
signals that R&D scientists look for when
discovering new targets.
With the right sort of development, this has the potential to then
enable us to stratify patients for clinical trials
for drugs which target nucleotide metabolism,
nuclear transport, and other metabolic pathways with eventual
opportunity for translating to companion diagnostics.
Across all of these three areas,
the H&E-based approach offers a potential
to stratify patients into subgroups that are metabolically
defined, having serious implications for
new drug development and discovery.
Across these categories from a translational perspective, we
identified three pathway categories that had cross-cancer
predictability. First, the nucleotide metabolism, which
was present in testicular germ cell tumors, determined in pancreatic
cancers and lung adenocarcinoma, which could potentially
have important implications for anti-metabolite
responsive tumors, which are either current standard of care or
undergoing trials for several tumors.
The second one around nuclear transport was enriched in
colorectal adenocarcinoma, melanomas, and two subtypes of
lung cancers.
This brings forth the XPO1 inhibitor programs, which are
currently being trialed for several solid tumors.
And finally, fatty acid beta-oxidation, which was
enriched in four tumors, all of epithelial origin.
This indicates a consistent cross-cancer signal, which
potentially offers a route to stratify patients for emerging
fatty acid oxidation targeting therapies.
So to summarize, we demonstrated that a deep learning approach
can potentially decode functional metabolic states directly from
H&E images. We identified three metabolite pathways which have
strong reproducible morphological signatures
across multiple cancer types,
and that the platform could potentially be utilized for biomarker driven
trial enrichment with the right level of development, potentially offering
a scalable, cost-effective complement to traditional molecular
testing approaches by using H&E only.
In terms of the next steps, we are focusing on external validation on
multiple independent cohorts post further
development. This will be integrated with treatment response
data to ensure that the approximations actually tie to treatment
response and inclusion of
datasets from normal tissues, before progressing to clinical
utility assessment in prospective settings.
The work would not have been possible without the efforts of my co-authors,
with research led by Dr. Salim Erslan, alongside Cher,
Fiwoz, Julian, and Vaishali, and our collaborators, Professor
Jakub Kathar and Dr. Oscar Mikes, and our
supporting organizations. Thank you. Welcome questions.
Go ahead.
Yeah, great talk. So I have a question.
You focus on 33 metabolic pathway, but essentially your
methodology could
work on all the hallmark pathway. Why not just do all hallmark pathway
focus on those high prediction power?
The other thing is, you mentioned at the end that you tried to use HEE involved
score to link to the target therapy.
So wouldn't be you first should use the ground truth to see whether the
ground truth had the power to specifically target.
Because if even the ground truths have no predicting power, why bother even do
HEE for the feature?
So, if I got your question correctly, the first part is why did
we not focus only on the highest predictive pathways, and the second part is
why use ground truth if it has no predictive power. Am I correct?
Yeah. Well, essentially the first that you use metabolic, what's the rationale
use metabolic pathway compared to many other pathway? Yeah.
Did I understand it correctly that why do we use metabolic pathways?
Yeah. So, one of the reasons why we used metabolic pathways
was rather than individual metabolites,
was predominantly because,
just a couple of days ago, we actually showed in a poster where we
showed that even if a biomarker is present, if your downstream signaling
pathway is not active, if you give an inhibitor, the patient is less likely to
respond. So it has therapeutic implications.
So that was one of the logic behind focusing on the entire metabolic
pathway and functional activity as opposed to single biomarker statuses.
But you have other pathway, like non-metabolic pathway.
Why-
Oh, yes.
It is not a part of the study, but we have shown elsewhere that you can look at a
variety of different cell signaling pathways as well.
So among those pathway, metabolic pathway had the best power?
Is that what you claim?
Among all different type of pathway, metabolic pathway have the best prediction
power?
Sorry, I don't follow your question.
That's okay. That's fine.
Sorry about that. But we can talk later.
Thank you for the interesting talk.
I have one question.
You evaluate the metabolism
in a patient slide level, right?
So essentially what we are assessing is an approximation of the
metabolic pathways because the way these personalized genome-scale
metabolic models were developed was,
it was derived from RNA-Seq expression data,
which used it to develop mathematical models of what metabolic
networks would be active within those patients.
That was work which was already done by another group.
Yeah, but
when I see your slide,
you used the tile level
imaging.
So if you predict the metabolism,
it should be integrated in a
whole slide level. How to aggregate them?
Yeah, so the outputs that we actually gave were
aggregated across tile level to give a
image level status. That's how we normally
provide the results. We do have a certain
threshold, cutoffs in terms of what's the minimum amount of
confidence scores that we would need in order to be able to consider this
as positive or not.
But my colleagues can share more details about exactly what
thresholds they use, and how did they aggregate it at a
tile level to give a single level output.
You mean that you did not use the some-
So the predictions are made on tile level but then aggregated at a
slide level.
Yeah. Okay. Thank you.
Yeah.
I have a quick question.
Did you try a simpler approach just using GSEA kind of
ranking to look at metabolic pathways rather than
GSMM because it's simpler, more accurate, and also
allows you to use more of the information on other genes?
Yeah, that's a great question. We are doing some additional work
around that. We've done some preliminary work,
but we were doing it in parallel so this one seemed to be quite novel
and we decided to present that first.
Thank you.
I have a slightly technical question.
Why did you use
256 by 256 samples? Like
pixels. Why not use bigger samples?
Why that
size, and does it matter?
Yeah, so
there is an impact in terms of
the pixel size-- Sorry, the image size or the
tile size that you use. We've optimized it for 256
by 256 because that gave us a good balance in terms of both compute
but the degree of predictability as well.
We've tried other scales as well, and depending on the type of
biomarker, you can optimize it a little bit more.
In this case, it seemed to work quite well for an early-stage feasibility study.
Nice.
Okay. Thanks again.
Great. So next we have Hanieh Ajami, from
Moffitt. "Enhancing Lung Cancer Risk
Prediction with Longitudinal Fusion of LDCT
Data."
Thank you. Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you so much all of you attending this session.
My name is Hanieh Ajami and today,
I'm PhD student from the University of South Florida,
as well as graduate research assistant at the Department of Machine Learning
Moffitt Cancer CenterToday, I'm very pleased to present
our work on early detection and diagnosis of lung cancer.
We've focused on enhancing long-term risk prediction
by longitudinally modeling the low-dose CT time
point data.
So lung cancer is a leading cause of cancer-related
mortality with an estimated of
approximately 227,000 new
cases and
125,000 deaths in the United States in
2025. And its prognosis also remains poor,
with five-year survival of 32% for
non-small cell and only 9% for small cell lung cancer,
making the early detection the most crucial strategy to improve
the survival. Lung-RADS is a
current clinical standard that is a standard reporting
system using the low-dose CT time point, and
it categorizes the finding and assigns follow-up
guidance.
Despite the value, it has
important limitations. For example, it has a
relatively high false positive rate, particularly in
category three and four,
that leads to unnecessary follow-ups.
As well as it may over-diagnose
slow-growing lesions that will never become clinically significant, and it
relies on the radiographic features and does not
incorporate personalized risk
stratification.
In AI world, Sybil is the current state-of-the-art
AI model. You can see the architectural detailed
design of this model on the screen.
This model accepts one single low-dose CT time point,
and then it outputs six annual risk scores.
It has reported a reasonable discrimination
ability.
However, despite the value, this approach also has important limitation.
It relies on only one single low-dose time point, and therefore
it ignores the temporal progression of the disease
over time. Also, it does not incorporate clinical and
demographical risk factor in prediction.
So because the temporal progression of the disease is important over
time,
suspicious patients undergo periodic low-dose screening.
So we hypothesized that
fusing longitudinal features derived from multiple low-dose
CT time points can enhance long-term risk
prediction and generalizability rather than relying
on only one single
LDCT time point. So based on this idea, we have developed three
distinct deep learning architectures with two variants on each named hybrid
architecture, bifusion architecture, and trifusion architecture.
Sybil, that presented to you in previous slide, has been
used in our study as a pure feature extractor.
You can see the detail
here on the screen that in hybrid architecture,
for each LDCT time point, we extracted the
Sybil's encoded feature from its CNN backbone as well as the
attention features
from its multi-guided attention mechanism.
And in bi and trifusion architecture, for each LDCT time
point, we extracted the Sybil's
final
embedding before fed to its HazardNet.
So in hybrid architecture, you can see that
we have the baseline T0, T1, and T2.
These are
actual
denoting the LDCT time points. And
we have the encoded features from Sybil, and we pass them to a
vision transformer. And then we fuse them with the attention feature
of that same scan. These hybrid architectures are closer to the
reality because in reality, all the
participants have not a complete
longitudinal scan. So they can handle
this missing time point either through explicit
temporal ordering or through attention masking.
Finally, we concatenate this representation and pass them to a temporal
transformer that learns the disease progression over
time. And finally, the HazardNet outputs risk from year one to year
six.
Then
in bi and trifusion architecture, here we have explicit
number of longitudinal samples. For example, in bifusion, we
explicitly concatenate two LDCT time point, the baseline and
first follow-up. And then we concatenate them and pass them through
either multi-perceptron or temporal transformer.
And the HazardNet outputs risk from year
two to year six. In trifusion, we have the same architectural
design, but actually we
explicitly concatenate three scans, and the HazardNet
outputs risk for year three to year
six. The dataset we have, we first longitudinally
model the
sample for participant. We pre-process them according to Sybil's
pre-processing pipeline to ensure the compatibility, and
then we extracted the features. Our first primary dataset is
the
LDCT arm from National Lung Screening Trial.
In this trial, we
identified all the cancer cases, and then
we randomly selected the controls with the ratio of one to three,
and
split the dataset 85% for training and validation and
15% for the test held out.
And we tailored this cohort to actual design of the
architecture. And then we also validated this
developed model on external validation
fromMoffitt cohort that we
have, and we also process them with the
same overall processing that we have for national and from
NLST dataset. We further fine-tune the model on Moffitt
dataset as well.
So here, on this table, we can see the detailed
result of the model's performance in ranking
discrimination ability between high and low risk
groups. And we actually
reported the AUC and C-index
performance. We can see on NLST dataset, the hybrid
architecture achieved the strongest
ranking ability with almost
perfect AUC at year one and gradually decreased
over time and remained 0.94 year six.
We also can see that the bi and tri-fusion architecture achieved
reasonable
mid-horizon performance
as well. Compared to the Sibyl that these models
had the
strong ability for discrimination.
And also on Moffitt dataset, after fine-tuning, we can see that the hybrid
architecture also remain as the strongest
performance on Moffitt, and
the rest of the models
have a reasonable performance in generalizing on Moffitt
as well.
We also using a statistical test, we ensure that the
differences between the models are actually
statistically significant. So this
work indicates that integrating multiple
low-dose
CT time points and the features
together, fusing them enhance the long-term risk
prediction and generalizability compared to
one single low-dose using low-dose
CT time point model. And it has the potential
for earlier diagnosis and
better personalized risk stratification
and,
therefore, we can have better personalized
screening strategy as well. So for future work, we
aim to incorporate clinical and demographical risk
in our prediction as well as extending our external
validation through multi-institutional cohort,
through federated learning, which is under implementation and
also explore real-world deployment
for
robustness and clinical utility.
And I would like to appreciate my esteemed principal investigators
at Moffitt Cancer Center and University of South Florida
and my esteemed lab members, and thank you for listening.
I would like to answer any questions.
Great talk. I will start with one question.
So why focusing on risk prediction rather than cancer
diagnosis?
Thank you so much for bringing up this question.
So about to answer this question,
screening and risk prediction and diagnoses are
a completely two different tasks.
So, when we are talking about screening the population
in this
study, they mostly
are not diagnosed with the cancer.
It means that any signal that is
apparent and is diagnosable on their
screening, it is not yet there. So,
during a screening, they come to the screen, they are high risk, but
they have subtle, slow evolving
temporal pattern that are not yet
diagnosable. But looking at this
pattern, the risk is actually elevated
for the long term. So,
this is especially important for our work.
We are focusing on
earlier diagnosis, and it will create the opportunity
for surveillance, closer follow-ups, and
sooner treatment.
Yes.
Good. Thank you.
Okay, very nice. I have a question. Well, it's more of a clarification.
So it's cool that you're using longitudinal data because that's
not often seen in machine learning approaches.
Does it matter how far
apart those scans are? Does it matter if they're
consistent in their timing, like is it every year?
How does that impact accuracy, the kind of dynamic
aspect, I guess, is what I'm asking.
Thank you so much. It's very great question regarding
the actual time that this periodic scan that
was taken. So
in NLST, we are working with very clean data that
the scans that are actually taken at yearly basis.
So there is a fixed gap between the baseline, first follow-up, and
second follow-up scan. And that's the actually one of the
reason that the hybrid architecture and the rest of the models
actually achieve very
good, strong performance in this discrimination because of this
accurate gap. But actually, when you look at Moffitt, which
is
kind of data that
we have a different gap between the follow-up, the
time.
Mm-hmm.
So that's one of the reason that actually we can see that the
model after fine-tuning, this could be a
potential that why the models
hadLittle challenge to work with
MAFIE because the data, that gap is something very meaningful
as a signal that is added to the model, and
it learn actually this
timing because of the temporal transformer actually that we have
here, and it emphasize on the positional encoding
during our model development as well as
because it actually learn that gap.
And so when it is at yearly, I believe
the model would
perform better compared to MAFIE that this gap is
actually
different.
Okay.
Thank you.
Okay, well, if there's no more questions, let's thank again.
Thank you so much.
Okay, and now we move on to the final
talk for today, and this is from
Jingyuan
Wang.
And she's going to present predicting gastric cancer
response to anti-PD-1 first-line treatment
based on multimodal data, and this is a multicenter
study.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone. My name is Wang Jingyuan from Fudan
University Zhongshan Hospital. It's really my great honor
to be here to present my study.
Disclosure.
Yuan Liu and Yu Jiang are employees of Yangtze River Delta Guochi
Intelligent Medical Technology Company, while the other
co-authors declare no financial relationship to
disclose.
Expected for PD-L1 expression, no predictive marker
for immunotherapy has been identified in the first-line treatment
of microsatellite stable gastric cancer.
Individual biomarkers are inherently limited in their ability
to reflect the full tumor immune landscape.
By focusing on a single dimension of tumor biology, they
often overlook the intricate and multifactorial
interaction within the tumor immune environment that
ultimately influence the therapeutic response,
thereby reducing their value for precise patient
stratification in immunotherapy.
Recent advances in artificial intelligence has
made it possible to integrate a multimodal
data including radiomics, pathomics, and genomics features
to achieve a more comprehensive depiction of the TME.
The multimodal frameworks provide promising opportunities for
a deeper understanding of tumor biology and for more
accurate prediction of treatment outcomes.
Most existing data rely on
unimodal datasets. Our study aimed to develop a
multimodal deep learning model by integrating clinical features,
CT-derived radiomics, and H&E-based pathomics to
accurately predict the efficacy of the first-line immunotherapy
in gastric cancer.
Pathomic features were derived from the whole slide images
using CLIME and a CNN Transformer framework, which converted
large-scale WSS into structured graphs.
Subsequence features were further extracted using pyRadiomics.
Radiomic features were derived from CT scans after manual tumor
delineation and subsequent
extraction for the finalized regions of
interest using pyRadiomics. Multimodal
integrations were performed by combining pathomic,
radiomics, and clinical data through a self-attention-based fusion
model to predict the
efficacy of the first-line chemoimmunotherapy in gastric cancer.
Interpretability analysis including cell type quantification and
transcription analysis.
One hundred and eighty-one patients has enhanced
CT scans, and 163 patients has
H&E slides.
Eighty-four patients of them had both of them, which were further
divided into training and internal validation cohorts.
Twenty-three patients with RNA sequence data were
further used for the biological analysis.
Three independent cohort from Nanchang and Xiamen hospitals
were used for the external validations.
Baseline characteristics were shown in the table.
Body tumor and intestinal tumors are more prevalent in
Fudan cohorts, while PD-L1 CPS
over one was the lowest, and the
metastasis in one organs were more
prevalent in Nanchang hospitals.
We firstly established the unimodal radiomics models.
Although the unimodal radiomics models could predict the tumor response
with AUC of 0.96, the predictive values
in the validation cohort were not confirmed for PFS and OS.
Similarly, we also established unimodal pathomics models.
These models could predict the tumor response of AUC of
0.95. The predictive values for
PFS/OS
in both the training and validation cohort were not further confirmed.
In order to explore the holistic
characterization of tumor environment and improve the
predictive values of AI models, we further
integrate clinical information, radiomics, and pathomics
data to establish the multimodal models.
Here we call it the CRT models. The AUC for tumor
response predicted by the established CRP models is
0.97 in the training cohorts.
Patients with a predictive partial response status by CRP
models showed a significant longer PFS and OS compared
with patients with predictive non-PR
statusThe predictive values of
CRP models for tumor response, the PFS and OS, were also
further confirmed in the validation cohorts.
To further explore the independent of predictive values of CRP
models, the multivariate analysis revealed that the
association between CRP model with PFS and
OS remains significant after adjusting age,
sex, and the PD-L1 expression in both training and validation
cohorts.
These predictive values for tumor response, the PFS and OS,
were also confirmed in two external test cohorts.
The CRP model outperformed the uni models
derived from radiology or pathology alone in all the cohorts.
Given class imbalance, we additionally evaluate
precision-recall performance. Across all the cohorts, the
multi-modal CRP model performed better than the uni-modal
radiomics and pathomics models.
The confusion matrix shows that the multi-modal CRP model
consistently distinguished predictive PR from non-PR
cases across all the cohorts, indicating the robust
predictive performance and the good
generalizability.
We also do some interpretability analysis, we compare the cell
type fraction by model-predicted PR status.
Compared with the non-PR group, the predicted PR group tended to
show higher tumor fractions.
And sequence analysis also show that significant difference in gene
expression between the predicted PR group and the non-PR
group. Reactome analysis identifies that a gene enriched in
the predicted non-PR group was
significantly associated with immune inhibitory pathway, including
CD22 mediated BCR regulation,
IL10 synthesis, and inflammation pathway like
NF-kappa B.
GSEA analysis also revealed that alpha and gamma
response were mainly enriched in the predicted PR group,
which were previously
reported to be related to immune suppression,
were mainly enriched in the non-PR group.
In summary, our findings highlight the promise of multi-modal deep
learning in precisely identifying patients who are the most
likely to benefit from first-line immunotherapy in gastric cancer.
The CRP model outperformed uni-modal models derived from
radiology or pathology alone, as well as the PD-L1 CPS
score. Tumor from gastric cancer in predicted PR groups
was significantly associated immune-related biological
processes.
Special thanks to Professor Tianshu Liu, the chief of
the Department of Oncology in Fudan Zhongshan University,
for her exceptional guidance and support.
And we also would like to thank all the patients,
collaborators, and the research teams from Yangtze River
Delta Guochi Intelligent Medical Technology Company.
That's all
for my report. Thank you.
Okay. We have time for a couple of questions.
Can you talk into the microphone? Sorry, we can't hear you.
Sorry, your voice is very small.
Can you check if the microphone's switched on?
Because it might be off,
because we can't hear you.
Do you mean the different drug of immunotherapy?
Yeah, the drug. Yeah.
Okay. Could you-
So while in your slide you talk about immunotherapy, but there
are many type of anti-PD-L1 drug.
So
your group, they are just treated the same type of anti-PD-L1 drug,
like K, all drug, or there's a mixture of different type
of anti-PD-L1 drug?
Oh, I don't think the type of PD-L1 drugs
have a bigger impact on the patient's
survivals. I think they have the similar efficacy
in patients receiving the first-line immunotherapies
according to the clinical trials.
Okay. Well, I have a quick question.
So on the kind of PD-L1
ability, that's a standard
in clinical practice, where they
look at the PD-L1 levels to decide whether they should give
immunotherapy or not. So how does your approach
compare to PD-L1 alone?
First of all, the PD-L1 CPS scores, I think it is
not very consistent between different pathologists.
And also PD-L1 CPS scores
is just one dimension of the tumor
environment. Here we integrate clinical information,
radiomics, and
pathomics datas. I think it provide a more
comprehensive characterization of the tumor
environment for gastric cancer patients.
Agreed.
Another quick question. So what are the next steps for getting
this into clinical practice?
So first, I think
because the
total number of our cohort is just around
200 or 300
patients. So I think we should enlarge our populations
and
validate our results in real world
studies. Yeah.
Thank you.
Thanks.
All right. So if no more questions, I'll quickly summarize.
I prepared slides just in case we have a lot of time, but we are lucky
that you will be spared from my slides, and I'll just very briefly
summarize what we have seen today. So very exciting work.
We've seen different prediction tasks, diagnosis
and classification, drug response prediction,
and also some feature extraction.
We've seen the use of more advanced and more
well-established older models, and both of them
are doing very well for different tasks, so that's great to see.
And yeah, thank you very much for listening, and it's been a very
interesting session.
Thanks, everyone.